hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
nintendo ihr habt zum titel richtig
gelesen wir kosten und heute ein
was wählt man nudeln da schon wieder ihr
habt zum titel richtig gelesen meine
damen und herren wir kaufen uns heute
einen neuen hund ja war nur du bist und
bleibst immer noch mein kleines
schätzchen ich weiß ich wollte
eigentlich mir für den ballon dahinter
eine schleife holen das wird in der
nächsten folge passieren jetzt setze ich
es mir als ziel jetzt muss es passieren
wenn du kleiner als der knuffig ich habe
nämlich einfach so behind the scenes ein
bisschen weiter gezockt und wenn ich
etwas ausgehen viele geräte schon 739
euro
ich habe nämlich noch einen wettbewerb
gewonnen das ziel von nintendogs ist ja
so ein bisschen jo man holt sich immer
mehr holen und man hat spaß und spiel
miteinander und dazu kommen wir jetzt in
dieser folge wir kaufen uns nämlich
jetzt einen zwergpudel und zwar ein
weibchen gibt es keine weibchen und weiß
ein sehr sanftes weibchen das alles leid
dass alle leute gegen ging wie so komme
ich aus deutschland ich kann nicht
sprache nicht zum ersten mal hat einige
zeit wie sie sich an die neue umgebung
gewöhnt hat wie soll es ein wenig mit
seinem hund spielen bevor er einen
spaziergang macht oder an wettbewerben
teilnimmt war jetzt wird mir gesagt den
augen hat ein leckerli
wie wird gesagt ich soll mit dem hund
ein bisschen spielen der einzige der am
start kommt es ballett gelernt was aber
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die
seifenblasen und spiel sein bis
katja wundervoll ich gehe jetzt erstmal
zum haustierbedarf um zu schauen ob ich
hier irgendwo was hab ich denn hier
nicht zum spielen irgendwie ich weiß nur
dass es damals möglich war irgendwie so
kann ich nur sachen verkaufen
damals war es doch möglich irgendwie so
roboter laufen zu lassen und die hunde
damit spielen zu lassen und da irre ich
mich da jetzt gerade ich warte jetzt
einfach mal zu mir
schaut sie euch an mit ihren kleinen
süßen mein gott die ist ja zu
was soll das denn ja super jetzt sieht
balu hier natürlich wieder richtig toll
im weg und wir können uns nicht um die
andere
wie wollen wir die andere eigentlich
nennen
na ja so toll ja super aber ich will
dass die andere hierhin kommt sie
scheint sich etwas beruhigt zu haben
sicherheitsdienst schon ein name für
dein hühnchen eingefangen nein ist es
nicht
da dies ja dass probleme wie
brainstorming jetzt mal ein bisschen ich
überlegt mich jetzt drei namen ich frag
mal eben kurz bei twitter nach 2000
jahre später ich habe jetzt gerade auf
twitter gefragt was die achter sind
schon antworten anne-kathrin jeder spaß
nennen sind mir seinen eigenen scheißen
namen auf twitter schreibt anne jazz
schreibt jazz kathrin schepp kathrin
kitty schreibt hello kitty laura
schreibt
das ist eigentlich sehr nice justin
schreibt pixel wolf das da ist die tür
okay die 90 prozent schreiben
tomatensaft wir haben drei
auswahlmöglichkeiten für das hündchen
ich will aber euch bestimmen lassen die
erste auswahlmöglichkeit ist budell
dafür pudel
damit beschreibt lächerlich die zweite
möglichkeit ist martina für ja so anja
max genannt in unserem meine freunde
video was ihr euch hier mal verlinkt ich
vergesse das video hier zu verlinken
also googelt einfach meine neue freundin
und die dritte möglichkeit ist
schneeflöckchen finde ich auch sehr süß
die sache jetzt halt nur wenn ich jetzt
mal wieder weg zum ingame hier gut denn
nun soll den hund einnahme halten laut
ausspricht
jetzt muss ich ihn natürlich aussprechen
da ich jetzt nicht gedacht hat dass das
so schnell geht einen hund an den
haushalt sich gewöhnen zulassen würde
ich sagen
nicht das video an dieser stelle kann
ich jetzt nicht sogar abstimmungen
machen ihr seht jetzt hier oben eine
abstimmung oder nicht oder ich weiß
nicht wie auf jeden fall ist hier eine
abstimmung und da könnt ihr jetzt sagen
er soll schneeflöckchen martina oder
modelle heißen und da könnte jetzt drauf
klicken oder auch nicht oder die am rand
irgendwie so ich habe keine ahnung wie
das ganze hier irgendwie ich habe keine
ahnung wie das ganze sein soll mir wird
nur von google geschrieben jahren kam
das geht man du kannst jetzt abstimmung
machen nicht so abboniert main kanal
deswegen kann ich jetzt auch gar nicht
viel mehr machen weil ich das euch
entscheiden lassen willst du bereitest
das video nur so kurz war ich glaube
sogar ist wales video allerdings
schreibt mir doch mal bitte über diese
abstimmung oder in die kommentare was
ich wie ich den hunden sondern außerdem
snap chat ich das hier gerade alles ich
mache in letzter zeit immer so ein paar
behind the scenes wenn ich aufnehme
damit ihr das schon früher wenn ich ein
video hochrangiges basecap chat laser
luca endet nicht dort und kauft auch
meinen merkel habe ich gar nicht an bei
euch jetzt jetzt wahrscheinlich so jo di
gallura das video war voll scheiße du
hast den hund gekauft und hass danach
nur gelagert aber sowas muss auch mal
sein und ich will halt euch die
entscheidung lassen wie der unterhalt an
einer hätte deshalb blöd also diese
blöde die hätten im internet und
beleidigen und warum macht man sowas
ich wache jeden morgen mit einem lächeln
auf weil man selber kann nur den tag zu
einem tollen tag machen wenn man froh
ist und wenn man froh ist macht ein
anderer leute auch froh und ich verstehe
diese ganze hate sache halt einfach
nicht ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt zur
bibel ist und ob das testament eines
videos aber ich würde sagen es euch
gefallen ich mich immer bewertungen
freuen macht diese abstimmung hier und
schreibt mir die kommentare wie der hund
zu heißen soll und man tschüs